ja schlangen gibt es nicht das ist alles
ganz gut geregelt mit die zeigen wie die
leute hierher kommen aber das können
1000 leute am tag geimpft werden
sie kommen von 8 uhr morgens bis acht
uhr morgens ihren das ist eine von
sieben sehr große riesige im zentrum in
england aber insgesamt mehrere hunderte
kleinere auch im ganzen land und ja die
leute kommen schon vor im moment sind
die leute hier tragen die 70 ihrer art
80 jahre alten alle die in pflegeheim
aber insgesamt haben wir jetzt fast
erfassen 9 millionen menschen geimpft
aber ich muss dazu sagen das ist nur
eine dosis ist es weiter dosis bis zwölf
wochen später passiert sie läuft in
großbritannien die im vergabe die
terminvergabe ab bei uns ist es ja oft
noch etwas chaotisch man kriegt briefe
zugeschickt oftmals falsch adressiert
oder es erreichte menschen die bereits
verstorben sind wie läuft das in
großbritannien ab es dort digitaler als
in deutschland ja in england haben wir
das vorurteil dass wir hier nach
schnellservice haben das ist ein
einziges datenbank und es wird dann die
leute ausgesucht von geburtsdaten der
wert der waren auch diesmal die leute
die über 80 jahre 65 jahre dran jetzt
sind die 70 jährige dran an dass ihr die
vergebung die wollen alle impfen
die über 70 jahre sind bis mitte februar
das ist 15 millionen leute an die wollen
auch alle die über 50 jahre alt sind bis
anfang april empfängt aber das ist schon
sehr viel vor aber hier ist auch
ziemlich gut organisiert wie sie sehen
dass es hier manche city fuß burg klopp
das ist ein tennis tennis club hier wo
die hier in pfund
das hat alles mitgemacht wir haben 5000
soldaten im ganzen land zum beispiel die
haben auch geholfen das aufzubauen die
helfen auch mediziner von der armee
helfe mit impfung alle herzen im landes
ist wirklich ein riesen ein riesen sache
des jeweiligen versucht hieraus sobald
aber ich muss auch dazu sagen dass dies
wirklich dringend ist wir haben über
hunderttausend tote
und mehrere leute mehrere tausend leute
immer noch ein krankenhaus und die
medizinische experte hier in england
wirken dass noch mehr sterben könnten
das ist wirklich sehr eilig das sollte
bis finde ich besonders die ältere leute
dass die sehr schnell geimpft werden wir
sind bild und wir liefern dir deine news
auf youtube zum nächsten video kommst du
hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren